ừ ừ
anh alo các bạn nghe thấy mình không Alo
Em à mình copy nhầm rồi phải bởi hai
đúng ý
à à
à Hôm nay chắc không đông được như buổi
một đâu thế này à thịt gà thế cũng hay
bớt loạn nhé
Ừ chị à à
à Hôm nay thì như nhiều bạn muốn nhiều
bạn hỏi nhiều bạn thắc mắc vân vân thì
mình sẽ chia sẻ cách hoạt động của web
cụ thể là các sao tự nhiên lượng Xem
giảm một nửa Khi mà mình bắt đầu nói
chưa ạ
ờ ờ ờ
Ừ thì tí mình sẽ chia sẻ các bạn cách
hoạt động của 1 web em Treo theo để gọi
như thế nào theo những kiến thức mình
biết được thôi có thể mình không Chưa
hẳn bên mà nhà
quản trị mạng không chuyên bên mảnh mạnh
ấy thực sự thì mình có thể là không giải
thích chi tiết được nhờ mình nhậu mình
sẽ Dạ sẽ nói qua theo ý hiểu của mình
Ừ có gì sai Các bạn cứ góp ý nhé chắc là
không hẳn là sai thôi Chỉ có thiếu thông
tin ý mình nghĩa thế đôi khi mình dậy
thì mình sẽ cố hạn chế mà sai không sai
cái gì đó thì các bạn gây hiểu nhầm hàng
gì đó Bởi vì lời nói ra đứa con có và
quay video thì rất khó để mà rút lại
đồng ngon nhưng mà
mình sẽ không chia sẻ những thông tin
sai lệch các thứ tin không chính xác
theo mình sẽ
trả lời chung mà mình biết gì mình nói
được đến đấy thôi ok
Ừ đúng rồi mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn nộp
bài tập như nào nhưng mà hôm nay mình sẽ
trả lời xấu hơn chính xác để các bạn
hình dung được là các bạn kiểu chia sẻ
bài tập hay ạ trang wep các bạn ra ngoài
Internet là như thế nào
ừ ừ
A
và đương nhiên là sau đó đi sẽ là chia
sẻ về bảo trong HTML để mình làm thử cái
bài 3 hôm trước mình bảo và cuối cùng là
chia sẻ một chút kiến thức mới thì thực
ra đây cũng chắc là
Ừ chắc là thỉnh thoảng phải nhờ các bạn
đã có bạn là biết qua những cái Trang
web nào hay các thứ thứ thì có thể góp ý
ờ
anh có thể inbox inbox trực tiếp mình
cho đỡ trôi là kiểu có những gì Hay mình
chia sẻ Các bạn khác đúng không vì hồi
mình đi dạy rồi ra mình cũng còn lưu lại
khá nhiều cái thứ hai để chia sẻ sinh
viên nhưng mà đương nhiên là kiểu nó vẫn
không không thể đủ hết cho tất cả các số
buồn bởi vì có nhiều cái hay thì phải
đến gần cuối khi mà các bạn học xong lập
trình rồi thì mới hiểu được nó mới thấy
nó hay còn về ví dụ ra giờ xử giống như
về HTML này thử về HTML này để hai cái
hai về nói thừa là cũng không hại nhiều
lắm đâu
cho nên lên kiểu bình mình chắc là cũng
phải cần thêm các bạn có đóng góp nó
ngon
em inbox trực tiếp mình qua một vài
discord hay là Facebook các bạn thực ra
là các bạn là tìm kiếm thông tin hơi bị
Hơi bị vẫn còn hơi bị kém một tí của
việc thực tế thì tên của mình mình để nó
chi cho tinh là nó nói ấy các bạn tra
tên của mình trên Google gái là ra hết
toàn bộ thông tin đến vì mình Công khai
mà
Ừ mình không để lên Facebook bởi vì ạ
hình như mình đã nói đây làm cái kênh
kiểu gần như là đang kênh mình không
mang Thiên hướng là kiểu cái tôi của
mình ở đây nên là mình mới không để link
mày cái đấy nha các bạn sẽ về mình thấy
ta vẫn tra được
ạ
Con à thực ra là mình lúc đầu mình còn
định hôm nay không định livestream sớm
như thế này
anh bởi vì ở kiểu
mình cũng ta không biết được à Bình
thường Hồi trước mình sẽ livestream sớm
để tâm sự một cái gì đó
à Hôm nay thì được nhà vừa rồi Mình còn
phải vừa xem lại gấp là
video Hôm trước có những câu hỏi gì Các
bạn thì thực ra là câu hỏi có vẻ cài
càng ít đi hoặc là trong buổi học mình
đã trả lời hết rồi Ừ nhưng mà thế được
cả hơi buồn vì á nói chung và vẫn những
ngày đầu tiên ý chỉ các bạn hỏi rất
nhiều Xong rồi những ngày sau có vẻ Đang
vơi vơi dần đi
Cả ngày hôm nay còn vắng hơn đúng không
Không mày đúng nghĩa là
anh không theo phong trào nữa Có gì thế
hoặc là mình dậy không đủ hay không biết
được
thì đáy vừa rồi Mình bảo là mình sẽ cắt
các bạn làm góp rồi mua tiếp theo
HTML có phải là ngôn ngữ lập trình không
à à
a HTML chấm như ở hội buổi đầu hôm trước
có rất nhiều không kiểu đùa không biết
đuổi thật nhưng mà tôi tôi từng thấy mấy
cái bài đăng hay hay đấy rồi đó là dùng
HTML để hack lá xa các thứ thứ
HTML không phải là ngôn ngữ lập trình
ngân hàng ra là không thể làm được cái
gì cả thật Alo Nó chỉ là kiểu nó là ngôn
ngữ đánh dấu văn bản nếu mà ông nào cha
nó dịch ra là thế xét cũng thế ở trong
hplc s và là hai cái thứ kiểu nói chung
là để làm về giao diện nên là nó không
có không phải ngôn ngữ lập trình
Ừ cái ngôn ngữ lập trình thì à để đỡ
mông lung như các bạn nào mà cũng chưa
thực sự hiểu khái niệm nó thì nó đại
khái như là
em có cần phải có liên quan đến vòng lặp
để có và có những cái điều kiện
chợ đêm Hạ kiểu
kéo điểm lặp đi lặp lại làm cái gì đó
hoặc là kiểm tra nếu đúng thì làm đều
không thì dừng chẳng hạn thì đấy mới
tính là một nguyên chất trình ít nhất là
như thế
Ừ nhưng mà đã tôi đã từng xem một ông
làm hầm một cái bắt kit ở trên mạng để
biến HCl thành ngôn ngữ lập trình cũng
buồn cười cậu Thế ư
a tiếp theo về cái vụ chia sẻ tâm sự ở
chỗ gà mình như mình đã nói người ta bây
giờ mình cũng chẳng biết tâm sự cái gì
nếu mà liên quan đến nhé cái
Ừ cái công nghệ Tạm thời như thế
à à
Ừ ừ
trước khi vào buổi họp với tôi sẽ trả
lời mình qua mình câu này nhé Thực ra
câu này không liên quan gì buổi học làm
đâu nhưng mà do là nhiều cũng từng hỏi
và nếu ông đừng thắc mắc thấy tiếng động
lạ kiểu gì nữa tách ra một cái thì tôi
giới thiệu lại quảng cáo nhưng một lần
nữa là nhà tôi thật là khá lắm muỗi và
tôi dùng cái đèn
gọi để hút muỗi như thế là đèn thế Chính
xác là từ chuẩn mềm thu hút muỗi đấy tôi
mua mua cái đèn đấy của đại sinh
đèn hút muỗi
Tại sao tô quảng cáo này thì tôi vẫn
khẳng định à nó tốt vãi chuột mua cái
này
Ừ cái này giá tầm này thôi Mày không
đứng ở không cần lấy mua giày quá mà
không cần mua đất quá tôi cắm cái này à
Tôi dùng cái này hơn 2 năm rồi Gần ba
năm rồi không phải là cả minh tục từ đấy
đến bây giờ nhưng mà rất ít khi tắt nó
và đến bây giờ vẫn chưa cháy kiểu nó vẫn
cẩu sạch tách tách tách ông thầy liên
tục đúng không
sao là tốt thường ta không thể nói nó
thay ngủ được vì Cơ bản nó dùng này này
ánh sáng xanh và nó sáng hơn đôi khi nó
sẽ làm cho mắt mình
Ừ nhưng mà nhiều lúc tôi cũng dùng nó để
mà soi hiểu đang chụp tắt hết đèn đi rồi
Rồi mở cái đèn đấy thì thỉnh thoảng soi
đường cũng dễ mà
Xin chào bạn bệnh nhân Lê Thị
ờ ờ
ở đấy mà cho tôi trả lời được câu đấy
rồi đúng không tiếp theo thì tôi xin
cách chia sẻ một vài cái cái cha mà tôi
thường hay đặt
ờ ờ
Ừ cái trang media 11 phần hôm trước thì
các bạn thấy mình thường ấy chia sẻ
nhiều về để trang trip along rồi đúng
không
xong rồi có cả Trang ạ vibro rồi nữa
mình thường ai đọc trên trang này
để hai trang kiểu tiếng Việt mình đọc
sau đó thì ở bên nước ngoài thì mình đọc
medium lẫn cả ở đôi khi là qua loa với
đít mà qua là thì ra nó nó bị cậu nó
không phải mỗi kiến thức mà nó trụ mà nó
diễn đàn
qua la thời ra nó còn chia sẻ kiến thức
thì nó hơn
ờ ờ
ở cây xăng medium này thì
Ừ chị nó khá hay cho khuyên mày không
nên đọc đương nhiên là giống như hôm
trước mày ông xe mà tôi phải chị lại DNS
để mà vào được cái trang này à
sau khi cái hay lại ở cái trăm media Mày
tôi thấy nó là kiểu Bùi thiệt nó trả
tiền cho tác giả đứng như là mình cũng
làm mất phí ở đọc cả có một vài cái miễn
phí thôi như thừa có cách để lách điều
đấy ạ là ông sẽ được
ở trong một khoảng thời gian nhất định
sau đó là bắt ông trả phí mở sườn rang
lên người đọc tiếp tiếc là như thế thì
ông không lưu lại được cái bài đấy không
đăng nhập để lưu lại được bài đấy nhưng
mà
Em đang làm tạm thời thủ công thì mình
nữa thì làm thế đúng không
Ừ cái á cái nói chung là Trang này nó
khá chất lượng bài đăng rất trước lượng
như là đương nhiên Thì nãy giờ tôi nói
gì đây là Trang tiếng Anh đúng không còn
mấy ông là nếu dân công nghệ thì mới ông
lên trang keyboardlock lẫn cả viclo
trang kivala cũng chỉ tôi thấy bài chất
lượng rất nhiều nhưng mà về cơ bản là có
vẻ ít người biết đến trang này hoặc là
Trang ngày chất quá nên kiểu bài đang
đầu dưỡng khác khi tôi không biết nhưng
mà bạn đang chưa này có phải ra ký còn
mẹ đang trên này thì công nhận là nó đa
dạng quá phá dạng theo kiểu là
đôi khi có những cái bài đăng của cơ thể
chất lượng nó chỉ rất là bình thường
theo kiểu này nó đúng kiểu lấy từ bài 5
gốc từ tiếng Anh Và Nó dùng như kiểu
Google rồi cái rồi đăng lên thành ra là
có thể chất lượng tùy Thần Bài nào mới
tốt
à à
ở mấy trang dạy phải bảo mật ta tôi
không về dân bảo mật tôi không đi chia
sẻ mình mấy ông mà cái trang gì về cái
đấy
nhưng mà Vừa rồi tao còn vừa mới còn
bước qua hình như tôi có cái trang là
whitehat.vn này nó xem người tin tức này
kiến thức các bạn để bảo mật những các
thứ thôi Tôi vừa nãy tôi vừa xem lại
xong này đây
cả ngày Tối chia sẻ với ông nhé
à à
thế này có khi Ông đóng hết cái này tốt
đấy
BKAV
có sao nhờ kiến thức cơ bản về bảo mật
ra ổn mà đúng không ạ
à à
- Bo kivala của mình á không hiện tại
đến bây giờ mình chưa đăng một cái 35
người cả hết thế nên là các bạn không
cần phải tra thì qua lót hay là vibro
của mình làm gì đâu
à à
Ờ Ờ bây giờ bắt đầu vào buổi học ở mình
xin phép trả lời những cái câu hỏi có
liên quan hơn đúng không đầu tiên là
mình
mà tại sao anh để đuôi HTML nhưng nó
không ra hình chiếu ông vậy ạ một là
theo ý của của bạn này có thể nó hiển
thị gian cái trình duyệt khác thì vẫn
được thôi các bạn giả sử nó ra bằng Nhi
nghe nặng do là các bạn cài để phô
pháp này các bạn chỉnh cái web Browser
Nó là một cái yeah chẳng hạn 21 S2 gì đó
thì khi mà các bạn mở cái file
khi các bạn mở một cái file đó lên đúng
không
Áo kiểu kiểu file như thế này lên các
bạn mở file lên thì nó để mình mở cái
bẫy hôm trước nhé
bộ lồng tiếng
School ở đây đấy hôm trước mình thích
rồi quên mất
ở đây
Ừ thì các bạn có thể chọn Open with này
cho chọn
cái gì đó sau đó thì bạn chọn cái trình
duyệt khác rồi Có bạn ấn away như này
thế Có nhớ nó sẽ luôn mở bằng cái chính
cái cái câu cái phần mềm tiếp theo các
bạn
về sau đỡ phải mất công chọn lại nhưng
mà
Ừ nhưng mà bé ở trong trường hợp mà các
bạn lưu đúng bởi vì hôm trước có bạn như
mình thấy ra các bạn vẫn còn quên các
bạn không biết ăn ốc sên ẩn video này
em tắt cái này đi Này các bạn ạ Các bạn
không không hiển thị ra cái đuôi chùm
tới tê cái gì đó thành ra là các bạn
không xóa được cái đuôi mà đi những cách
tốt nhất để mà tạo một cái file như thế
này thì các bạn dùng sắp litek để mà tạo
thì nấu ăn hơn cho bạn ạ
à à
cho mình mình sẽ dạy lao nhưng mà sẽ
khóa học sau nhé
à à
chú
ý bạn là select file to preview này thì
các bạn Ấn mivue này xong rồi ấn tivi
Pana hơn em ạ Thì đấy nó sẽ chỉ đây thôi
I
I went home của mình thì đang dùng cái
merdu đấy à các bạn nên trân trọng cái
mail edu của trường các bạn để mà kiểu
vì nó có rất nhiều Hôm nay chính mình
chính minh là người Ờ phải kêu gọi sinh
viên là shimmer edu của trường đi bởi vì
a murder trường có rất nhiều cái chỗ các
bạn đăng ký miễn phí được rất nhiều tài
liệu miễn phí dành cho Midu các bạn hoàn
toàn tra freephone edu rồi hôm nay mình
vừa tra xong này đấy thì nó xảy ra hồi
trước có cái trang là for medication
cover.com cơ
nhưng mà hình như ông ấy không ra hạn
tên miền đấy là ông ấy chết rồi
sao tự nhiên Google mình không
không tìm kiếm được bạn đã đây như này
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ thấy có rất nhiều cái
thứ mà
có thể đăng ký miễn phí hoặc cả giảm giá
rất lành mạnh cho Midu
à à
khách sạn hạng
a tiếp theo là mình xin phép chia sẻ cái
blog của mình một tí Tại sao bởi vì mình
muốn cho bạn nói qua các bạn nếu mà các
bạn dùng sau đây cách giống mình ấy thì
mình à mình chia sẻ về những cái kiểu
những cái lắc in nó gọi là lắp đi Bọn
back in tiện lợi ích mà mình cài cho cái
sắp like để mà màu màu các bạn thấy màu
nó khác khác với cái á
cái các bạn đang cày kết hợp với mình có
chỉ một vài phím tắt bây giờ Bây giờ
mình sẽ thử mở cho các bạn thì các bạn
hãy đặt phím tắt này Ui nó khi nào vãi
tại để nhìn thử mở lại các bạn nha à
các bạn hãy màu nó khác các thử đúng
không Thì buổi bởi vì a mình có cài cái
sau khi mà gọi chim.bac MT rô này các
thử thế này và và chỉnh đây là một vài
cái chỉnh nữa của mình để cho nó đẹp kết
hợp với Chỉnh căn cho Huyền này đây con
chuồn Huyền này là một cái thứ rất là ở
đây thì mình mình hiểu chị các bạn nhé
chọn là khi furka body này rồi cắn cho
Huyền này đây để tự mình gõ nhá từ ca là
các bạn hoàn toàn toàn thể dùng cái kính
tắt khác mình thích mình thấy căn Xuân
Huyền ở trong cái này đánh hơi vô dụng
Nên mình đổi cân xuất hiện vị Đình Vỹ
Đình Nó là cái gì đây để mình thôi
Em thử cho các bạn đây là mình ra xử là
mình chưa tát lùi ở dòng và giống như
hôm trước mình làm để ngon mình à
Cantona Bôi đen tất cả này làm cho Huyền
đấy thì kỳ ảo và sẽ tự động
số tự động Tab ra đầy đủ
a cho bạn nhưng nhưng nhé với điều kiện
là các bạn phải đóng
Anh đóng
có thể chuẩn Mở thẻ chuẩn thì nó mới
hiểu được để má áp vào chuẩn cho các bạn
đấy
Ừ Thế hai ông thấy kỳ ảo rất hợp cho
những cái ông nào kiểu lười ấn Tab
mở màn nhớ các bạn nên dùng Tab vào để
lùi đầu dòng là như thế này chứ các bạn
không nên dùng dấu cách nhé em
ở bàn chân này thì ra tôi có chia sẻ cả
bản quyền sắp ai cách của tôi rồi có
nhiều ông thì thắc mắc đều lấy bởi vì
tôi từng nói hôm trước là là tôi tốn 80
đô để mà mua cái này mà đúng không
trợ cây cái thứ duy nhất có nhập cái này
vào ngoài việc có tên tôi ra thì công
khi 160 Tech nó không nhìn thì em một
cái bóp lại chị Thoa nói Hiển thị các
bác là mày mày hãy mua bàn bất kỳ đi đấy
thì thì nhập cái này vào nó sẽ không
nhìn thấy cái to nữa đúng không ạ
ở
ngoài ra còn những cái Pocket ở đây nữa
thì mình có chia sẻ rõ là nó tác dụng là
gì rồi Có rất nhiều nó Pocket Đúng là để
dành cho pepula hơn tí kia các bạn học
xong cái đấy các bạn mới cảm thấy nó sức
sự quan trọng về chưa em
Ừ tự nhiên công học miễn phí không ăn
hết cho tôi ờ
cô đơn vị của trong web hiện đại nhìn
thấy chủ yếu là dẫn dùng là Tết và video
nhé và có bạn hôm trước hỏi là tại sao
dùng à khi mà gõ hai ngày không cần ký
Pixel bên cạnh bởi vì ở thời gian Cái
này là quy ước của dòng Facebook của
thằng HTML nó hệ đối ngoại
A và cuối cùng đừng dẫn tương đối và
tuyệt đối có bạn nói có này rất hay
nhưng thực ra là đôi khi mình hay quên
mất cái từ này còn tiếng Việt Bởi mình
đặt tài liệu tiếng Anh hay nhiều nó là
kiểu như này tuyệt đối Nó là kiểu như
thế này đây là đường dẫn tuyệt đối đừng
dẫn trước đối là tức là nó sẽ có từ đầu
đến cuối luôn một cái đường dẫn để đến
với file nào đó như thế này
có gì à đừng dẫn Tức nối là như thế nào
các bạn sẽ để ví dụ Giả sử cái file của
mình để môi trường mắt em à Lần này mình
xin phép mở cả thư mục lên các bạn dễ
nhìn nhé
đài các thư mục Ẩn em
tắt đi à Ừ cái file đến môi trường HTML
này của mình không ạ Mình làm nằm ở
trong thư mục HTML Thì bây giờ mình để
đến được cái file ảnh này thì mình có
thể trôi theo cách này Đầu tiên là file
đang ở đây đúng ạ Mình sẽ có chấm chấm
Xô kéo nhé Hãy chấm chấm này bản chất là
nó sẽ thoát ra khỏi phải trục mình không
biết 1.23.1 gì không nhớ chúng mình nó
chỉ chứa hai chấm mở như thế này nó sẽ
thoát ra khỏi cái thư mục này là sửa
Mình thoát ra khỏi thư mục đó ông ạ Có
phải thư mục này mình sẽ đến thư mục này
đúng không ạ thì mình sẽ phải gõ đầy đủ
tên thư mục của nó bị sửa đây mình sẽ
cotton tên thư mục nhá này suốt chéo
Phát nữa để vào trong thư mục đấy đầu
ngoặc Sau đó anh thép mình sẽ có thêm
một bài lát này thì mình lại copy tiếp
đó ngon
máy xúc chéo tiếp để vào trong thư mục
Bà Lát rồi cơ thể cứ thế đấy là sự cơ
thể từ cái này nhà này đồng ngoài đến
được thư mục chỉ cách để đương nhiên là
b và mình đã hướng dẫn làm như thế con
cách để mà các bạn là đỡ mất công gõ đi
Gọi lại như thế các bạn nên vào trực
tiếp vào đây cho nha Ngoan mình mình thử
vào cho nhanh nhé
Anh bài 1 này
xe tải thì mình sẽ ấn party Đà Nẵng sau
đó mình copy cái đường dẫn này là được
này sẽ copy đúng hướng dẫn này ạ
ở đó sau đó Đương nhiên là mình vẫn sẽ
cho chéo Các bạn thấy xuộc nào thì ra
chụp nào được thôi Vì nhớ không lầm mà
như thế Mình lấy thử nhé Mình cần mình
cứ thủ đã nhớ nhưng mình lâu hôm làm nó
không biết đúng hay sai tên file này
à mà chấm vip Cái quan trọng là cái chấm
đít này thì các bạn viết hoa viết thường
thì cái chấm này nó không quan trọng nhé
Nó không vấn đề hoa thường đâu
A tại mình chạy thử file xem điều nghĩa
vẫn được đúng không Nghĩa Các bạn thấy
là sụp chéo chụp chéo như thế này hay
sụt chéo như thế này thì cái nó vẫn như
nhau đều ngoan ý
à à
nghe giọng tối hay vì tôi có cắm mic đắt
tiền đấy mời ông về sau Nằm chiêm bao
thấy không nên mua mình à
đấy Nói chung là À đúng rồi tranh thủ
vừa rồi mình có nói qua vụ không phân
biệt hoa thường thì về các bạn HTML nó
đúng là nó không phân biệt hoa thường
luôn là sử là mình
Khi mình mở phạm một vài cũng cũng vẫn
là quan này đi mình xóa hết đi này à dự
án sử đầy H1
Hello đi này chẳng hạn
mình chạy thử nhé
em à Đang lên đây mất rồi tao đi Nè đó
các bạn thấy hoàn toàn là
a hoàn toàn là kiểu nó trong phân biệt
hoa thường thì cả đúng không ạ
ý nghĩa là nó vẫn hiển thị ra đúng thậm
chí nó còn chơi đêm kiểu như này vẫn
được không thì sai cả đúng không Nhưng
mà thực tế là các bạn hạn chế nó chùa
không nên luôn Nó là khuyến nghị kiểu
thế là các bạn nên viết hết Không Không
biết hoa viết thường ấy đâu mà Bởi vì
đôi khi như mình đã từng nói đó là có
thể trình duyệt UC nào đó sẽ bị sai phạm
Vân Loan vẫn nó không hiểu cái thể đấy
phải gì
html5 mà người không phân biệt hóa
thường thôi thì nhớ chị rất là đấy vẫn
HTML phiên bản cũ hơn là nó phân biệt
hòa thượng đấy thì
ông bà có thêm một bạn nữa thắc mắc là
thật sự em quên đóng thẻ như này thì sao
không ạ Các bạn thấy được ra chẳng sao
cả Nhưng mà như này đôi khi các bạn sẽ
bị mày cả lỗi kiểu dạng giống như là mấy
cái dòng dưới này thì nó sẽ bị hưởng
thừa hưởng hai cùng điểm lại những sự
biết đâu nhé thì nó vẫn sẽ bị kế thừa
Nói chung à các bạn quên đóng thẻ cái gì
đó thì coi như là toàn bộ những hình sau
đó sẽ bị ảnh hưởng
à à Trên màn hình ngang mà mình đã từng
chỉ các bạn phím tắt rồi nó là Dùng
Windows Windows mũi tên là các bạn sẽ
chưa được màn hình ngang à
ừ ừ
à à
ở đồng hồ Windows mũi tên Windows mũi
tên là sẽ chia màn hình ngang các thứ ba
vẫn thiếu các bạn chuyển cái cái cửa sổ
này cửa sổ ứng dụng này nhảy sang màn
hình bên kia nhanh và xử lý có 2 màn
hình mà đúng không thì các bạn Dùng
Windows rồi ship một mũi tên nữa thì nó
sẽ nhảy sang màn hình Mickey anh anh
đúng không ạ
anh nói chung là mình thì biết rất nhiều
phím tắt
kiểu thế và mình khuyên các bạn cũng nên
thế để mà làm mọi thứ nó trong nó mượt
nó hiệu quả nữa nhé ạ
ở mũi tên là mũi tên Sang trái sang phải
thì nó sẽ thế Mình nghĩ là có một vài
cái Các bạn cứ nên làm nhiều thì các bạn
sẽ các bạn phải thực hành luôn đấy để
các bạn nhớ thì các bạn hỏi rồi thì các
bạn sẽ lại quên thôi
Đấy mình chia sẻ xong rồi không ạ Thì
bây giờ mình sẽ cách chia sẻ cái cách
hoạt động của một trang web
a cho nhiều bạn vừa nãy có thắc mắc đó
là các bạn à các bạn đầu tiên đầu tiên
là mình cứ lên trang của mình để xem các
bạn với Hôm trước có đăng bài tập rất là
nhiều Thực ra là mình có đọc thế tất cả
bình luận các bạn nhưng mà chị bình luận
hỏi thì mình mới trả lời thôi Bởi vì
tiền các bạn nộp bài nghe mình thấy rất
vui nhưng mình trả lời hết cho các bạn
mình chẳng biết nên nói gì mình không
muốn cậu văn mẫu hay cậu làm
bạn Bạn ổn rồi nhé vân vân mình cái trả
lời văn mẫu cực
anh
nói chung ở bài 1 này về các bạn thì nó
vẫn dễ nên là mình xin phép là mình tạm
thời chảnh chó chỉ chọn đúng Nói cho
mình tạm thời mình thử xem mình không
trả lời gì cả trừ khi là các bạn thực sự
hỏi bài thì mình sẽ trả lời lại bài 1
Nghe bài Một buổi một bằng như thế
và mình thấy là các bạn có vài bạn biết
sử dụng ghim cũng nhờ băng hẳn có hẳn
một cái trang riêng gì gì đó nhưng mà có
nhiều bạn thì ra vẫn không biết về vụ
đấy Thì bây giờ mình sẽ giải thích sâu
hơn một tí là cách thức hoạt động của
website
mình mình học về web mà kiểu gì mình sẽ
phải biết phải đấy
số đo kích thước không hoạt động của
website ví dụ Giả sử có bạn Đây đây là
một cái file của mình đây đúng không ạ
Được sự đây mai của mình đã sử có chữ
xin chào anh em ạ
Như này mình không phải copy cái file
này gửi đúng cái đường dẫn này đúng
không bé đường dẫn nhưng đây đường dẫn
file Nhưng mà đừng dẫn của trang web
đúng không khí không này gửi đường dẫn
này inbox cho một bạn ở đó rồi bảo ông
chạy thử xem cô có lỗi gì không vì gì đó
Bởi vì thực sự thì cái này mà gửi cho
người khác người khác không có cái hoa
này trên máy của người ta để người ta
chạy được đó ngoan khi cách để mà mình
gửi file cho người khác xem hoa cả kiểu
băng lên trang web để cho tất cả mọi
người cùng xem đúng không khái niệm đó
là gì thì các bạn phải hiểu thế nào là
của internet đã cái này thôi bị sông tí
Đọc đoạn đầu tiên nhé cái khái niệm Ừ nó
kiểu dạng là bị bây giờ là à mình có cái
file này đâu mà mình muốn cho tất cả mọi
người cùng xem thì mình phải công khai
cho
công khai ra ngoài internet
cho cái địa chỉ ip của mình
ở mỗi mày nó sẽ có khái niệm là cái khái
niệm địa chỉ IP bạn thứ ba cái tin này
mình không nhớ đúng hay sai nữa Nói
chung là nó có một cái địa chỉ IP cái
xong rồi Bạn phải công khai cách công
khai cổng này để mở à mở file word các
từ thứ gọi mở tường lửa để cho thằng kia
vào được nhà mình đúng không Đấy xong
rồi gửi IP và các thứ cho nó thì nó mới
truy cập được vào trên máy các bạn
ở những cái đấy thức a + tôi không
khuyên công mở như thế còn gì Nếu thế
thì ông nào cũng vào được để nguy hiểm
đúng không Thì Cách thứ hai là gì thì
đương nhiên là cái thứ hai thì ông không
dùng trực tiếp máy của ông mà ông sẽ đẩy
size cốt này lên một cái server nào đó
server tất cả một cái con cũng như là có
máy tính của cậu các bạn thôi nhưng chả
qua nó chạy được 2424 thì ông đẩy cái
cái cốt đấy lên một cái con server để
như con server đấy cũng phải lên công
khai cho tất cả mọi người cùng truy cập
được con Server này mà các bạn nếu mà
các bạn à Bây giờ thì có rất nhiều con
server miễn phí để bạn tra A Gọi server
thì nó nghĩ nhiều quá các bạn có thể
tra theo kiểu hoc sinh hoc sinh miễn phí
Nó xảy ra nhiều hơn
thì cái hút sinh nó cũng là server chẳng
qua Hoshi nó là cái phần phần nhỏ hơn
server server Ví dụ web server là một
trăm phần trăm cấu hình thì con hút xinh
rồi nó sẽ chị là một phần trăm trong cái
đống cấu hình đấy Kiểu thế còn vô sinh
nó sẽ rẻ hơn rất nhiều và nó thường hay
miễn Thủy rất có rất nhiều các bạn hoàn
toàn thể
Lên đây đăng ký một cái con hút sinh sau
đó thì đầy cốt mình vào trong đó
thế nhưng nhưng ở đây bài toán là
đôi khi ở Bà con mua sinh này nó sẽ theo
địa chỉ IP gì đó các bạn lại phải copy
với địa chỉ IP đấy gửi cho ông kia địa
chỉ IP nào luôn là một cái dãy số thì đó
dãy số kiểu kiểu như thế này anh cho như
thế này đấy thì thì ra là rất hợp cậu
khó nhớ thì các bạn đã biết em khá nhiều
với hai là tên miền nó domain đương
nhiên là cặp đương nhiên làm cái răng hộ
thuê ô sin vừa rồi đôi khi nó cũng sẽ
đúng ơi chỗ mình đang bị bão ờ
Ừ thì à Chỉ Một Mà các bạn thuê domaine
Không có khái niệm mua đâu Chị có thuê
được thôi nhưng mà để nếu mẹ ông đang
đầu tư thì thuê domain hoặc là hết sinh
miễn phí kia thường ai có sẵn domain rồi
thành ra là các bạn chỉ cần áp vào mà
dùng thôi nhưng bây giờ đang kiến thức
nó rất là rộng rộng cho các bạn còn kiến
thức đơn giản nhất các bạn đó là các bạn
lên sử trang giấy tháp này
em
chẳng biết hát này giống như có bạn vừa
nãy nói mình thêm một cái ý rất là hai
nữa Bây giờ các bạn đăng ký trên này thì
nhất là nước miễn phí này thứ hai các
bạn tạm một cái Visa phô chứ Này các bạn
à phải tạm một cái Zippo nhé sau đó thì
em giả sử là tôi tạm một cái Bo này rồi
đi đúng ạ tôi tạo dưới po này rồi và ở
đây có cái file chấm HP pro của tôi này
tôi sẽ tạo hết cái file đẩy hết cốt lên
trên này sau đó thì tôi ấn vào bình
setting này xong rồi à nhớ không lầm là
bấm vào cái ở
đây nhờ cái bên mềm này ấn vào cái pic
này sau đó thì mình nhớ không lầm là bấm
vào cái gì đây để nó thành Tablet như
thế này thì nó sẽ có một cái đơn dẫn như
thế này các bạn Vào đường dẫn này thì nó
sẽ ra trong web rồi các bạn
ờ đúng à Thì
sau khi cấy việc đầu tiên thì nó sẽ luôn
vào trang là trang readme của các bạn
còn các bạn muốn vào được đúng cái trang
cụ thể ví dụ giả sử ở đây mình có một
trang này như thế này thì nó sẽ ra đúng
không
Ê cái code này hồi đấy của tôi làm cũng
hay phết xin phép xin phép quảng cáo một
phút một phút cái này là cái này của tôi
hôm đấy tình cờ
thấy một bạn rất là xinh xắn biết được à
chanh ly cân của bạn đấy nhưng không
biết được trang Facebook của bạn đấy
Ừ thì tôi chơi cách này ờ
Ừ tôi thấy cần của bạn đấy tôi biết được
công ty của bạn đấy Đang làm ở ngoài thì
thì tôi biết được mà kiểu gì mấy ông
cũng
Ừ kiểu gì mày cái bạn đấy đứa kia ở sẽ
tương tác với
anh
Fanpage của cái công ty của bạn để làm
ít nhất là như thế ít nhất thôi có thể
có thể được rồi đấy thì mình
thì mình sẽ nhập ID của cái test đấy vào
đây cho nhập tên người mà mình thích ví
dụ Giả sử bạn đấy tôi nhớ không nhầm tên
là chai này bạn có nhiệt tình chàng đây
xong rồi tôi nhập
tôi xem bạn đấy đã từng tương tác bất kỳ
cái gì liên quan đến ghép lại ẩn nơi đây
tìm đấy có thể chọn tên gần giống thôi
đấy tôi để tên gần giống và vì có có bạn
kiểu để ví dụ bạn này tên là Ánh nhưng
mà là do tên Facebook của bạn đấy anh ở
nào Nói chung vào bể cây này không có
dấu thành ra tên gần giống ơi chứ không
phải chính xác tên này Đấy giờ ok gái
tôi liệt kê toàn bộ những các bạn nào có
tên có chữ trang ở trong đấy hay gì đó
Thế Hệ kế hết cả lại kèm theo ảnh mạn
đấy
ô tô tường chia sẻ tôn này trên YouTube
committee rồi đến trải qua mấy cũng
không bị thôi
anh không thầy thì Vĩnh Cửu học lập
trình để làm gì đó
bộ phim
à à
Ê
mấy ông chị thế là nhanh Thế dở rồi tôi
chia sẻ đây không phải để mấy ông vào để
mà
Ỷ Lợi dụng tôn của tôi hợp phía đẹp bị
bán các thử thử nhé Mà đang mà đang ví
dụ để mà Mấy ông thấy là rõ ràng mấy ông
hoàn toàn thể làm cái đấy thủ công bằng
tay nhưng mà tìm cái đấy rất lệnh vất vả
Đúng không Thì bây giờ ông có thể dùng
bằng ngôn ngữ lập trình để mà làm được
điều đấy
đúng không Chỉ cần có ý tưởng thôi đúng
không Chỉ cần có ý tưởng thôi là sao
ngôn ngữ gì à Hồi đấy tôi làm hết thuần
bảng g Suite đấy à
Anh họp xong kỳ Sắp xong khóa này học
xong khóa này mấy ông chẳng làm được cái
gì là vùng mỗi trang web cơ bản thôi để
học xong khóa sau thì mình làm gì mà ông
muốn cũng được à
em có cái nước này thì học xong quá này
và khóa sau kiểu gì nữa không đủ kiến
thức để làm tất cả mấy tuần này mấy ông
lúc đấy Có khi vào bảo tung tôi đều kính
khủng em có thể làm tối ưu hơn này Vân
bận à
ở nhà mẹ ông Nam bắt đầu lạc đề đó
ừ ừ
Ừ Ok đó nó chua đang hơi đi xa quá mất
rồi nhờ bài hôm nay về các bạn nó nhắn
cái này ra là mình mới nó như thế đỡ
mình quay lại bài nhá á
ừ ừ
à à
chủ đề thì hôm nay mình sẽ fast mình sẽ
chỉ chỉ cho các bạn làm trang web kiểu
như thế này
ở cổng Kỳ thực tế đó là
từ khi mười dân Nói chung à Dần khi kể
web Bây giờ nhìn cái nhìn một cái kiểu
trang web xong người ta luôn hình dung
ra các ô các ô ô hiện tượng như thế dụ
điển hình giống như là Facebook thôi tôi
thì Mở Facebook lên Facebook của tội
nhiều cái nhạy cảm nhưng mà tôi cứ tạm
hi sinh vì anh em đấy khi các bạn sẽ
thấy ở đây góc bên trái này làm cái cột
này góc bên phải này là mỗi cột này khóc
ở giữa này cũng cả một nữa này có ba cô
chúng không mấy ông nỉ Story làm gì cả
đái thì
Ừ thì tôi sẽ dậy ông là bây giờ mình sẽ
dùng cánh bạc cái bảng để mà thiết kế
thế Kể ra thành các cột như thế nhưng mà
trước hết để mà làm được như này thì
mình sẽ gửi dạy qua thế nào là bạn ở
trong HTML đã để ngoan ý
ở đầu tiên thì làm việc với bạn đi nhưng
phải có thể thấy bà ngon Nó sẽ thuê thế
bồ này
a
tiếp theo là có thể tê rồi nè
ở tập trung tập trung tập trung alo Em ở
chỗ nào hẹn Thay bồ là thầy bà đúng
không Thế bây giờ nó là cái tắt của
table rows là hàng Đông Á
à mà tiếp theo là
thi công suy nghĩ và có hàng thì sẽ có
cột Nhưng mà không chắc nó sẽ là TD
TD là Thay bồ data
và từng cái này sẽ từ ngô một bây giờ
giả sử mình có mình muốn làm một cái á
a a thuốc miễn cứ mở bằng Excel đi ship
dự án xử Mình muốn làm một cái bảng kiểu
như này
ờ ờ
chờ đợi bình tĩnh lâu lắm mà bọn này họ
tên này quê quán càng ạ
ở đây lắm này Hà Nội này anh Tuấn đây ah
Anh
Tuấn
Sài Gòn cho là sự thế à
em với anh này cũng Hà Nội này chẳng hạn
như thế này
à mình cho phép hai người Hà Nội ở cạnh
nhau đi tí mình chị cho nó dễ
ở đài bài kiểu kiểu như này à
Anh tên chứ
Mà thêm cái nữa là họ đi
họ Nguyễn này à
ở nhà văn đi
Ok Để mình làm được cái bảng kiểu như
này để ngoan
Ừ thì mình sẽ làm như thế nào các bạn sẽ
thấy là cái cày hát em rồi nó luôn theo
quy tắc là từ trên xuống dưới Đỗ hoặc
trên xuống dưới và từ trái sang phải
nghĩa đầu tiên thì từ trên xuống dưới
làm mình sẽ phải làm trước thấy dòng này
đầu tiên này được đúng không Và tiếp
theo là từ trái sang phải mình sẽ làm
cái ô họ trước rồi Oh tên rồi Quê quán
Đông ăn nó sẽ là họ này
à Xong rồi tên này à
à
Xong rồi Quê quá này
à à
Vì sao lỗi tiếp theo là mình sẽ có là
lại PD tiếp tại sao phải TD tiếp bởi vì
ạ Mình sẽ
ăn rắm Gióng kế cái TD này gửi tới đây
này này là Nguyễn này à
Ô Long Trần Văn hóa á
Anh
và Hà Nội chả thế
à à
ở đây sẽ là nguyện Văn nó văn
Ừ anh Hà Nội
Ê
bà đây là mạnh tuần không ạ ạ
à à
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ chạy thử các bạn xem
qua nhé
ở đó
thì các bạn sẽ thấy là nó sẽ dám thẳng
một hàng như thế này nhưng mà nó không
có Nó không có cái viền cho cái bảng này
hay ra các bạn rất khó nhìn thì để các
bạn thêm viền này bạn sẽ có Model bằng
một như này
Ừ thì nó sẽ thêm việc gì này và các bạn
sẽ thắc mắc là tại sao không phải là số
1 gọi số khác là sử thay nó số 3 cảng ạ
Thế bạn thấy nó viên nó đậm hơn đấy các
thử nên là mình Nghĩa Viện một là ổn rồi
không hồi âm đó nhé này không có -0,5
thôi thì thì bay về miền tiếp theo là có
như mấy bạn đang đề cập vào Tại sao
không dùng cây hát đầu ngon thì cái đây
mình sẽ thử ví dụ các bạn luôn bị th các
bạn đang nói
bí đỏ đỏ lao
TH là khi tắt của table thấy bồ đã đi sẽ
copy đấy à
a
table hết điên à
cô giáo sư Mỹ cho thằng này th này thế
bạn sẽ thấy sự khác
Ừ vậy thì nó sẽ khi mà dùng cái th này
nó sẽ mặc định là in đậm và cắn nó giữa
Ừ đúng thế bạn sẽ thấy là cái này nó khá
phù hợp cho những cái cột tiêu đề
à Còn nếu t đêm bình thường thì các bạn
thấy nó chị in bình thường thôi
ở ngoài ra thì còn thêm những cái nữa
bảo là giả sử các bạn muốn hai cái cột
này vì các bạn nó đang giống nhau thì
mình để cho hai cột này
thứ hai của mảnh ghép vào với nhau điều
hòa thì mình ghét Nó kiểu như thế này
ghét nó kiểu dạng là
ứng dụng dùng này ghép này và cắt nó ra
giữa trời lặng là sự thế
ở đây
mình muốn làm kiểu cắn nó ra giữa như
thế này thì mình sẽ làm như thế nào đầu
tiên mình phải ghét cái 2 cột thành 1
thì bản chất là ghét Hai cái à nhầm ghét
hay ô ngồi ghép 2O hành hạ
Anh thành một ai ghét hay ô nằm ở hai
hàng thành một ô như này thì bạn chất là
kẻ ô ở trên này đâu ở trên nhé Nó phải
chiếm bằng hai cái ô nhiễm màn theo
chiều dọc hoặc theo chiều dọc
Ừ thì nó sẽ được khái niệm là
a rose PET bằng 2a
Lý Ngựa Ô này sẽ chiếm 2 Hà đều hoặc đây
mình sẽ chạy thử có bạn xem khi con nó
chiếm hai hàng thì đúng là nó to ra và
như thế thật đẩy ô này ra và Bởi vì ông
này đang bị chiếm mất rồi và đang thường
mất rồi ngoan bị xóa đi này đúng không ạ
ở ngoài ra là
Ý là mình cần ví dụ Giả sử là mình sẽ
ghép theo cả cả cái này ghép vào với
nhau thành họ tên chẳng hạn thì gì đó
đúng không
Em chỉ cần ghép theo chiều ngang để ngon
thì mình sẽ hoàn toàn là như thế này xóa
này đi nữa à
anh ở đây sẽ là cô span phần 2 nó sẽ là
ghét hay hay O theo chiều chiều ngang Cô
là có lum ý để bạn nào chưa biết thì dâu
là là hàng đúng không có luôn mà cột
đúng không ạ Ừ mình đang nói qua tất cả
những cái cần biết của cái này bởi vì tí
Làm bài tập từ sẽ có liên quan ừ ừ
Ừ chú kê Đây đây là toàn bộ những cái
các bạn cần biết cơ bản của Hằng Thay bồ
rồi mà bây giờ sẽ nghỉ Sáng mày tật
Ừ thế Tự nhiên thoáng qua đúng không
nghe thực tế nó lại hiểu
thì mình sẽ phải cần cái này biến hàng
biến hàng triệu bảng nó sẽ như thế nào
thì mình sẽ thử vẽ các bạn hình dung nhé
rõ dài Các bạn thấy ở đây nó là có 3 cột
3 cột
Á Đông
ở bài cột lại ở cột 1 Quận 2 quận 3 này
đúng không Thì
hai cây cột 1 và cột 3 nó giống nhau
đúng không nó kích cỡ giống nhau và màu
giống nhau và toàn bộ thông tin
an toàn bộ thông tin thì nó sẽ nhét vào
cột thứ hai nằm ở giữa đóng ngoặc
Ừ thì mình sẽ thử làm về cái vụ này
chứ không phải dậy xong hết tiền lời
mình mới dậy sáng CF được
Anh dậy từ từ mà nhóc à
có lẽ mình lại xóa hết đi này
vợ chồng chồng sơn đầu tiên mình sẽ có
thấy bồ nó ngon thế bồ này đây rồi à
a&p trước mình sẽ có 3 cột Nhưng mà
trước hết mình đã làm một cột đã có tiên
thì các bạn thấy là cột này của này đúng
không Mình sẽ cho nó là chiếm tầm 15
phần trăm
Ừ chiều chiều rộng ở nhạn chiều rộng của
cả cái bảng đồng hồ
Ừ thì mình sẽ ko with quý kiểu Nga 15
phần trăm như này và mình sẽ cho bgd Air
là Blue chẳng hạn để các bạn xem qua nhá
đó thì các bạn thấy ra rồi ngon và sự là
một cột ở giữa thì background color màu
trắng mình bỏ qua và mình hoàn toàn để
sáu ít cái này đi như thế này Tại sao
bởi vì mình HM nó sẽ tự động tính hội
cho các bạn là thằng ngày 15 phần trăm
hai mươi lăm phần trăm thằng ở giữa này
sẽ toàn bộ phần ở lại nhưng các bạn
không cần phải kiwi cho thằng này ở
đây Thế bạn sẽ thấy nó bé như thế này
Tại sao bé ngày bởi vì à Mình chưa trẻ
nội dung vào cho cái bạc kết hợp việc là
cái bảng này thức with của cái bàn Nó
đang bé Bây giờ mình sẽ quýt nó bằng 115
nữa ạ
à à
ừ ừ
số 15 phần trăm này là một phần mười lăm
phần trăm của cái thằng cha tất cả của
bà này thôi nhé chứ không phải là 15
phần trăm của cả trang web đấy do mà vừa
rồi mình phải thêm một trăm phần trăm
của cả trang web để 15 phần trăm lại sẽ
là 15 phần trăm của trang web đúng không
tại sau đó thì mình sẽ nội dung và giữa
này thôi
Thì bây giờ mình sẽ có cái ảnh đúng
không có vai cái ảnh
à à
ạ bây giờ sợ mình có cái ảnh nào đó
anh khuya lạnh đông
em copy tiếp
ừ ừ
Ẩm Thực ra là có cái có thấy Pocket Mình
nhớ có người ta kiểm ảnh có thể tìm kiếm
được ra cái ảnh này nhanh nhưng mà ạ
mình về cơ bản thì mình làm này nhiều
cho quen thôi
ừ ừ
khi thoát ra cải thư mục HTML này rồi
tiến hành để là được không chỉ cần như
này thôi
có ai suốt thì nên tuân thủ theo cái số
của nó
À mà đấy sẽ là
Em mở cái à
Ê mày lên đấy à
à à
anh bày kq là nóng
đó thì các bạn sẽ thấy bảng sự tự động
to ra khi mà kiểu mình chèn thêm nội
dung mà cho nó
Ừ đúng rồi thực sự là bây giờ không ai
chưa web bằng thấy bồ nữa
em yên tâm toàn bộ kiến thức mình đang
dạy có bạn biết rồi thì có bạn sẽ thấy
là mình đang dạy nó kiến thức còn rất là
cũ vân vân Nhưng mà hồi hồi mình đi học
là đúng kiểu như thế
nó nó là Kiều từng từng mức độ Tùng lên
lên lên dần lên dần ở ngoài thì các bạn
sẽ hiểu được bao quát nhất
Vì mình thấy thực ra đấy rất là hay đi
an toàn bộ kiến thức mà hôm
À hôm hôm trước học thì hôm nay gần như
là sẽ
sẽ kiểu xóa đi làm lại và làm theo một
cách khác ổn hơn
ừ ừ
anh em mình sẽ đến nội dung và không ạ
cho mấy bạn có thể bảo đang nó chán khô
khan Nhưng mấy ông thử dậy thử dậy Cái
này thì mấy ông ấy thấy thực sự nó chán
như nào bởi Thì bởi vì người đi dạy với
người mệt người người đi học tôi không
mệt đâu
Mấy ông không học có thể để giảm Nếu
không nghe nhưng mà người dậy mới bắt
buộc phải nói đi nói lại cái điều này
rất nhiều lần và người ta còn thấy cái
này nó rất là dễ rồi mà vẫn phải nói
Vì thế nên là Vì
thế nên là mấy ông phải thông cảm cho
nhau đúng không
Đây mình sẽ nhét hết ở đây mình chia sẻ
các bạn thêm tí nhé
ở đó lạc toàn bộ những cái ở đây giống
như mình đừng nói là mình nên làm khái
quát trước mà hoặc toàn bộ những cái đây
chủ yếu không nền đều là chữ ngủ xanh
nên là ngay từ ngay từ không Hỏi mỗi cái
nội dung và cho này màu xanh mà mình
muốn cho tất cả các chữ ở trong Tế đề
màu xanh thì mình nên có một cái thẻ
phone ôm luôn ông luôn cả Nói chung là
ôm ôm từ đầu đến cuối cái đây cũng được
Giống như kiểu như này ạ
Ừ không sao cả cái ảnh được là nó có ảnh
hưởng gì cả nhưng mà không có ghi trường
hợp tt này cho mồi cách ra phone các thứ
thứ được được đâu ạ
e-blue này thì cho tất cả chữ màu xanh
Nhã đứng như là bây giờ để xuống dòng
thì các bạn phải
anh phải mất công thủ công rồi Ở đây
mình sẽ chia sẻ thêm một cái mẹo nữa các
bạn dùng sound stack thì bạn hoàn toàn
thể
ạ bấm bấm chuột và giữ phím Control nhé
cần phím Control các bạn sẽ chọn từng
dòng như thế này
khi đôi khi chọn hơi lệch một tí
đấy thì ra cái này nhược điểm tôi khó
chịu thằng sau mới tách bà phải thế Chọn
từng dòng được giữa toàn cho rõ từng
dòng được như ai xong Em xong rồi gõ thì
nó sẽ có thể gõ được ở nhiều nhiều hành
cùng một lúc
Ừ nó kêu nha à
à à
khi dùng thẻ p cho mỗi dòng Á thứ đã
dùng thể được nhưng mà
Ừ nó vẫn không sai nhưng mà thường là
người ta sĩ Dung thể p cho cả một cái
đoạn văn bản Thực ra toàn bộ với thằng
này nên ôm ở trong một thẻ P
à à
ừ nóng thế thế xong rồi Ngon mà đương
nhiên có một vài cái chữ nó Kịp in đậm
lên thì dùng thiệp thể b thì mày đậm Các
bạn đã từng đã biết về vụ này rồi
xử như ai thì sẽ làm in đợi đó
ừ ừ
Ê bà cuối cùng là mịn mình mình sẽ chữa
do các bạn về cái này ạ
anh ạ
cho các bạn biết làm thế nào ở điều cái
nào thử trả lời mình sẽ xem ông nào học
trước rồi biết làm nào để đợi tí tắm
không ghét đâu Thấy không bắn trúng đấy
à à
Ừ chắc phải ta đi à
cách làm à để ra được đấy
anh em nào để nó cắn được đều nha à
Ừ đúng rồi đúng rồi nó lại dùng thêm bồ
tiếp đó là dùng Thay bồ xong nó sẽ căn
căn ra làm như thế này hay cụt sau đó
hai hàng như là ổn Đấy ông kia họ trước
biết cả Flex Thôi tôi không dậy vì Black
đâu
a
Flip a litte các thứ vãi chưởng nữa thôi
đơn giản thôi mình sẽ dùng Thay bồ và
các bạn thấy thực tế là thê bồ nằm trong
Thay bồ như này vẫn được đều hoặc
thế Bồ nằm trong thuê bồ như 2A
thì
mình sẽ có TD này bà đây sẽ làm cái ảnh
bạn thêm cái ảnh nữa mình copy cái đường
dẫn này cho
đỡ mất công này tiếp theo mình sẽ có cái
ảnh
à à
ở đây mình sẽ chạy thử các bạn xem nhé
Em nói như này
a
tiếp theo là có gửi ảnh nữa đúng không ạ
Nhưng sẽ lại thêm cái nữa cho sự hai ảnh
giống hệt nhau mình không quan tâm
nếu các bạn thấy ở đây lại bị một cái đó
là cái chữ này nó không cần ở giữa này
đúng không
các bạn ý kỹ là chữ này nó căn giữa ở
trong tiệm thôi bà cái bàn này cân nó
giữa thì để tất cả cùng camera giữa thì
cũng trước mình có biết qua vào mình sử
dụng ở like Center cho cả cái tên này mà
sẽ cần ra giữa
sau
đó thì các bạn sẽ phải cân ra giữa những
đây có bị nhược điểm một tí nữa đó là
các bạn thấy là bao giờ mình thêm chữ
các bạn xem nhé sự là chữ gì rồi đi mình
sẽ copy ở trên này cho nhanh nhé Không
quan trọng với cái chữ lắm
anh về đây này à
Ừ cái đề tiếp này
các bạn thấy là chữ ở đây nó Căn theo
đúng cái ảnh rồi nhưng mà nó lại không
căn đều ra giữa cái ảnh này một Cam Ranh
giữa chữ nó cân bằng giữa
không chữ này thì có thể không cần dưỡng
như ý thôi cái ảnh nóng cắt ra giữa đúng
không ạ
ô chữ có thể tăng này chạy được ảnh là
ra giữa và
A và làm nó bị đều được như thế đúng
không Thì và nó không bị sát và gái như
này không bị sát vào như thế này thì bản
chất ở đây đó đầu tiên mình căn lán giữa
thì mình sẽ dùng reisecenter tiếp thôi
đúng ạ
Ừ
nó cắn đứt giữa rồi
ờ ờ
khi phà cần cái này phải bé lại nó cần
phải bé lại thì nó mới cách được vùng
như này chồng ngoan
Ừ thì mình sẽ dùng vít 80 phần trăm để
em ạ
80 phần trăm này không phải không phải
80 phần trăm cả xanh web nhé 80 phần
trăm này chị sẽ kế thừa ta muốn phần
trăm từ cái thằng pê đê thôi và HTC này
lại kế thừa tiếp từ thằng này thôi à rất
là nhà nghỉ thế
ở đó thì các bạn sẽ thấy nó cắn là như
thế này để ngoại
em gửi tiếp theo thì các bạn sẽ thấy là
cái ở dưới này thì lại đơn giản rồi khi
các bạn làm được cái này thì cái này bạn
chất Nó là một cái bàn tiếp này đúng
không Mà nó sẽ là ba cột thôi Đấy con bể
màng được cái chữ có phong như này thì
như mình đã nói thì HTML thì mình chưa
học về mà tạo được cái phong như này thì
mình phải sang pcs để học
Ừ
nhưng mình vừa nãy nói thì ạ
Ừ mình đang dạy các bạn về cách chia bố
cục bằng bạc và có thể dùng bà để ứng
dụng được để mặt chia bố cục của trang
web
chứ không phải là khuyên các bạn dùng
bảng để mà chia làm trang web này bởi vì
thường nghe chẳng ai dùng nữa
có
những buổi sau dần dần làm bìa khi mà
sang CS thì các bạn mới thấy à cốt toàn
bộ những cốt như này nó phải xóa đi gần
hết mà mình sẽ phải làm lại mình còn
phải làm lại cái mới à mình phải làm lại
những bài này nhưng theo dạng út mới để
ngoan ý
xe đẩy thức a thế này xong bài thi bồ
đấy
anh cũng nhanh mà đúng
thì nó sẽ các bài thấy bổ chỉ có thế này
thôi nhưng mà nhưng mà đối với những bạn
mới được ra cái này đã kiến thức những
rất là mới và rất nhiều cái mới dồi rất
nhiều thẻ mới trong bộ hôm nay nên mình
cũng chỉ dậy đến thế này thôi
ở bài Buổi sau cho ca bài Buổi sau nó
nhảy sang thẳng em mới nữa luôn em thứ
là cái này không hẳn là sắp xếp theo thứ
tự đâu thì nhớ là đã gửi sau không đến
mức độ như thế
em buổi sau mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn về
à
cụ thể danh sách
em bỏ qua về thẻ danh sách
ai để ý
à à
a nay có bạn Phương Linh hỏi thêm một
câu rất hay không phải nhân nhiều Tab mà
là không không biết hiện ý của Đúng rồi
ulv không biết ý của mình có đồng ý và
đấy không mà là
bạn đấy nói về cái vụ đắp liên kết dòng
cốt đối ngoại là nhân dòng cốc lên nhanh
thì ở trong ở trong so với cách này thì
mình để mà mình nhảy mình không phải
control xe rồi căn cho ăn trộm xe nó cắn
trốn V như này đâu nhé và mình sẽ dùng
mà
I can't run Bôi đen Cắm cũng ah Mình rất
thích Bu đen Cả thêm ròng ròng ở trên
này nữa để mình khi đã kết mình nhảy
sang năm mới luôn và mình sẽ dùng can.be
nước ngoài cần D không còn thương xe đâu
nhé Cảm ơn C con xuân về thì thì thì nó
lưu lại vào trong lưu lại vào bộ nhớ
mình không thích điều đấy
ở đâu Mình không thiên vị nam nữ khi
mình đi dạy mình sẽ giúp mình đọc ông
nói thế
sau khi đi dạy nói chung là tôi đứng
đúng với tư cách của một người thầy Chân
Chính thỉnh thoảng trẻ trông thì thôi
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
em gọi trước khi hết buổi thì mình xin
phép
chia sẻ cái này
ừ ừ
Ờ Ờ cái này thì kiến thức không liên
quan lắm
em nói chỉ thiên về bên A
nếu cậu nóng phải hay hơn không liên
quan mình những cái mình đã được học
Ừ nhưng mà tôi thấy hay tôi chia sẻ với
ông ạ
ờ ờ
Ê có vài câu mấy ông đang hỏi đang đúng
cái câu mà tôi đã trả lời ở mấy cái á
buổi trước nên tôi không đề cập nữa đâu
nhá đi
ở đây nhà xưởng các bạn xem qua về trang
medium thì nó sẽ có quay một cái video
ngắn
hình ảnh nó lúc đầu được lót lên rất là
mờ sau đó thì vẫn nhé
ạ sau đó thì nó mới bắt đầu hiển thị rõ
ra các bạn sẽ nghĩ là có thể do mạng
Em dậy đi á hết buổi hôm nay đấy Dậy gì
nữa Ông muốn họp với nữa Hôm nay chị
buổi hôm nay chị biết về thấy bồ
Nghe có vẻ ngắn ngắn đi rồi là đối với
nhiều bạn mới thì nó là dài đấy các bạn
phải làm làm lại bài đấy mà à
Ừ Thì
em yên tâm tí sẽ có một cái chích Tôi
tôi đang chỉ ông ví dụ này vào tí rồi có
chích cho thì cái thứ nhất là mấy ông đi
kỹ lại tôi vừa chia sẻ nó là rõ ràng mà
Mấy ông thấy nó là cái ảnh mờ sau đó thì
ảnh bắt đầu bợ đỡ mờ lên và hiển thị lên
không
anh đúng không Thì mấy ông chị nghĩ là
gió mạnh để lúc đầu nó khiến em ờ như
thế sau đó thì nó mới to lên đúng là có
liên quan đến phần là việc là do mạng
nhưng mà mạnh ở đây là không khiến cho
ảnh mờ
Ông nhấn mạnh nhé Nó chỉ một là ảnh được
lót lên thẳng luôn hai giờ hay là phải
đợi màu trắng xóa xong mới bắt đầu mấy
nghìn Chị điên cái ảnh
Ừ chứ không nói chuyện là ảnh mờ Xong
rồi đến ảnh nét như thế bài toán ở đây
là chính Thằng này nó chủ động làm ảnh
mờ sau đó thì mới thì ảnh nét đâu mà nó
sẽ tạo ra một cái kiểu như này các bạn
nếu con nhìn qua đây sẽ đúng kiểu ảnh nó
sẽ loát trước cái ảnh có dung lượng thấp
nhất rồi mới bắt đầu Dần dần mới hiển
thị giá rẻ à Mới lót dần ra cái ảnh to
Tại sao lại phải mất cong như thế bởi vì
thực tế là một cái ảnh nét như này thì
phải lót rất lâu rồi ra được cái này
Đúng vậy thì nó sẽ tạo lòng gửi ảnh
anh hoặc và thượng nó tạm cái ảnh gọi
trăm yêu ơi nghĩa là ảnh kiểu preview
Xem trước và nó độ phân giải rất là thấp
sẽ thoát thì anh về trước một cái với
Cái kích cỡ kích cỡ lớn thành ra là cái
ảnh sẽ làm mờ như này kèm theo đó Nó
dùng Oppa City giống như có bạn đang đề
cập để để nhìn trông có vẻ Đang ra Cái
ảnh bây giờ là anh ấy đang rất là rõ nét
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi bạn chỉ đang nói rất đúng bởi
vì Giả sử cái ảnh nét nhất này Nó mất
công Mất tập 3 giây để Lost đ
Ừ đúng rồi mất 3 giây để loát thì khi
người dùng và cái trang web các bạn nó
không muốn nhìn thấy cái cái chỗ trắng
tinh như thế này mà nó cần phải nhìn
thấy ít nhất là cái mờ mờ như thế này để
nó hình dụng à cái chỗ này đang web ảnh
nhưng mà do mạng nhà mình có gần đây là
em ạ nên anh để cho lót xong chứ không
phải là nhìn thấy trang web trắng tinh
thì nó thì người dùng nó sẽ không hiểu
được cái chỗ tránh đấy bản chất là cái
ảnh nhưng mà đang mất công lõi thì đó
đấy thế nên là nó sẽ phải chiên ra kiểu
như này để ngon nếu như bạn kia nói rõ
ràng làm thế tốn thêm băng thông nhưng
mà người dùng lại thích kiểu thể cơ
người dùng ở thích kiểu kiểu dạng thể
thấy một cái gì đó xong rồi mất công
ngồi đợi nó thay vì cái màn hình thời
trang trắng tinh đồng phát thì thị luôn
cả cái trang web được không
10 cái này không đến nỗi 10 ảnh đâu Tôi
không biết học mail làm như thế nào anh
em mình không nghĩ thế Tiếp theo là cái
vụ này thằng thằng Google nó cũng áp
dụng thằng Google thì nó hiển thị ra
tông theo kiểu không phải hiển thị ra
ảnh kiểu mờ như này nữa mà nó chơi theo
kiểu là cái tông nền của cái ảnh gần như
thế để cái màu trọng điểm của máy ảnh là
màu gì Nó suy định trước và như thế này
sau đó đi dần dần làm loa đã được nghỉ
này
ở đâu ạ thì
khi người dùng vào không phải nhìn thấy
một vật trang trắng tinh mà hiển thị
trước những cái khung khung như ngày rồi
những cảnh như thế này thì người dùng sẽ
đội đúng không phải dùng sẽ sẵn sàng đội
để mà lót thêm được cái anh
thứ ba thằng Facebook nữa cũng chơi cái
trò này
À mà tôi không biết làm vụ này đó tôi
tôi đang chia sẻ tôi biết làm đâu
thằng Facebook cũng là vụ này và xem qua
cái cái bài của nó đây rất là hay
đậu xanh
ở đây nè Nó sẽ các bạn sẽ thấy rất nhiều
lúc thằng Facebook nó sẽ loa cái ảnh mờ
trước mà các bạn sẵn sàng đợi thì bị ra
cái ảnh to hơn thậm chí ảnh cover cũng
thế các bạn sẽ thấy là đây thường hay để
mà thoát cái ảnh profile sau đó loạt ảnh
bìa thì
Ừ thì người dùng phải đợi thời gian để
mà Tại hai cái này cùng lúc đấy thì ra
được ngon thì dùng đợi cái này sữa khó
chịu thay bình như thế thì sẽ hiện loạt
cái ảnh review trước sau đó thì mới
trong thời gian đấy thì download cái ảnh
trong nó sẽ đúng kiểu như thế này
Em có nhớ là có cái ảnh Ví dụ ở đây mình
nhỉ
em nhớ mấy ông Thực ra mấy ông vào vào
mấy cái trang cá nhân thì thoảng nó sẽ
thấy ảnh mờ mà
em vừa rồi nói qua một tí gì về
3 cách hiển thị là cái ảnh các thứ thứ
đúng không tự nhiên tại sao tôi để nói
vụ liên quan cái ảnh ở đây bởi vì
anh lại nhắc thêm về vụ đoán ảnh thì tôi
áp dụng luôn các bài này ra nhiều ông
không biết được và hoàn toàn thể lấy ảnh
được đây bằng cách chuột phải xong rồi
chọn Open imate như thế này lấy được ảnh
đúng không có biết rồi nhưng có mình
chưa biết
à chị
về bản chất là một khi cái gì để flash
lên
Ừ để hiển thị cho các bạn như này các
bạn hoàn toàn để lấy được cái đấy bao
gồm cả ảnh cả video gì thì bản chất là
lót được Tức là nó đã tải về sẵn trên
máy các bạn và các bạn hoàn toàn thêm
màu nó lên được là sự như đây mở lên cho
dù có nhiều thằng thì nó chơi trò ngẩn
đi ra sự giống như là tăng bồ phải toàn
bộ anh ấy lấy nick này nhớ dễ
thực a Free của tôi có nhiều cái cảm lắm
đó tự nhiên tại sao ra về Cha ngày đầu
tiên nghỉ thôi nốt nốt lại cái chai này
ạ
À mà thôi lấy loại anh ấy biết đậu còn
những nhà nghị cảm hơn đây là sự ảnh này
ông thấy rất rõ ràng à
Em bấm vào cái Download nó không hiển
thị ra cho ông cái Download bởi vì cái
kệ cây cây
hai tác giả này tắt cái hiển thị
download rồi
Ừ
cái gì Mẹ bắt đầu đi xa đấy tôi tin mày
không phải chuẩn bị đang nói xấu gì tôi
ăn thịt
em giả sử tác giả tắt rồi nhé nếu mà các
bạn vào những cái kênh Free của người
khác đôi khi là sẽ có cái nút ở đây cho
các bạn chọn độ phân giải để mà tải
nhưng mà giả sử tác giả tắt rồi thì các
bạn hoàn toàn thể bấm vào chọn vio sai
này thì vọng tác giả đây Đang không xem
video này cho các bạn ấn xem cái ảnh lớn
nhất này Đây đúng ngoài sau đó thì ấn
chuột phải vào
Ừ cái này là cái gì Cái này chính cái
HCM các bạn đang học đây này đúng không
open in new tab này đó thì bây giờ các
bạn hoàn toàn thì cân cho nét Thì Tải
ảnh bé rồi đúng không
tự học HTML để làm gì đúng không
Này cái thứ mà tôi đang định nói nhưng
mà tiếp theo tiếp theo nữa đây này
ở lại phim kiến thức nữa để mặc cao ông
có thể làm đó là bây giờ mình sẽ chuyển
qua Facebook
khi bé ông muốn tải ảnh từ Sorry không
ở
đây là video Đây là video đối ngoại
nhưng mà mình vẫn có thể tải được cái
video này bằng cách là
ờ ờ
Ừ nếu mà vội video ấy thì có ông ấn vào
bên fake sau đó ấn
đầu tiên các bạn mở inspect này
ạ sau đó các bạn ở trên Word mày xong
ngồi gõ chấm MP4 sau đó ăn fake
Ơ sao lại các bạn có thể tải lại trang
để mà nó hiển thị cảnh sát ở đây
ở cây Thử lại không liên quan đến html5
nhưng mà tôi đang muốn cho không hiểu
bản chất là một khi mà có ông đã xem
được cái đấy hoàn toàn không thể lấy
được đâu ạ
các video này
thì nó sẽ thằng Facebook nó có cơ chế
thì ra được cái video này thì nó đang
tải từng đoạn của video rồi nó ghét rồi
với nhau thì đây sẽ từng đoạn của nó có
ông ấy chất phải copy copy Linh
undressed này Đấy sau đó đi các bạn như
xóa cái đoạn
thế này đi này Bài bài start với bye and
cái đoạn này là như tôi vừa nói nó ghét
nó ghét lại cái cái video đúng không nó
sẽ bắt đầu từ bầu đầu và cuối ở đâu là
sự không Xóa này đi rồi ông sẽ lấy được
video gốc này
ở đó đấy sẽ video gấp đồng ngoại
a tiếp theo ở đây tôi xem có ví dụ bạn ạ
ở
đây mày Cái đây là ngạc thì chắc chắn ở
video rồi nè
Ừ Hình như đây là anh thì các bạn sẽ ấn
vào bên inkmax này thôi
ạ sau đó thì các bạn à xem ở đây sẽ ra
được những cái ảnh ở đây các bạn thì ấn
Ừ nhưng mà ở đây có nhược điểm đó là
thằng Facebook mà luôn tải trước khi
Story nên Hãy ra các bạn thấy có những
hình ảnh từ cái trước chứ đôi khi ở
không không đúng cái mà các bạn đang xem
đâu bà nó sẽ phải ảnh bao gồm cả ảnh đại
diện các thứ tư nữa đâu quá
ở Facebook của tôi thì đúng là có nhiều
gái hất nhưng mà tôi không
Không đến nỗi thành bên hai đâu nếu quen
tôi rồi nó cũng dễ thấy
ở đây Nói chung đại khái như thế này ừ ừ
à
À đúng rồi cái video vừa nãy lấy là mấy
ông còn đấy cả nhà ta nhé và mấy ông thì
ghét cả cái nhạc và video không tùy mấy
ông ạ
à à
a videos YouTube thì nó làm theo cơ chế
khác nhưng mà nhưng mà về cơ bản như mì
nói thì một khi nó đã lắp được về trên
trên máy của mình để rất nhiều cách để
mới lấy ý
anh Sơn nói chung là bây giờ cũng đúng 9
giờ rồi đúng không Thì vừa rồi là những
cái chia sẻ một tí của mình không biết
là buổi sau mình được chia sẻ từ những
cái thế không Hãy hết sự mẹo những đại
ca như thế
à à
khi mình đã vừa nói việc là
một khi mình ở xem được video đấy thì
chắc chắn là đồng nghĩa việc là nó tải
về máy mình rồi Đúng ngon Nếu khó có thể
chặn để mà không cho tải được ta chỉ có
thể là mình một là trạm không cho xem
hay là mình phải làm khó người cái vụ
tải nhưng mà kiểu gì bài toán ở đây vẫn
là kiểu gì cũng sẽ tải được bởi vì họ đã
mát được trên trang của mình về cho mình
xem rồi mà không
chú ý
à à
thế nào nếu mày nói việc khách khủng của
tôi nói tôi không khách mà tôi đang chỉ
cho ông mấy cái mẹo mày cái típ người ta
chích dùm cái Chích cái cũng hay anh
không bị hiểu nhầm xong với ông Chích cơ
ở được mà chết cả là những cái mẹo thủ
mẹo mẹo vặt thủ thuật để mà mày ông có
thể áp dụng gửi kiến thức công nghệ
thông tin để làm những thứ muốn
à à
Ừ thế nhỉ bây giờ thì thôi các bạn
đi chơi đi tối thứ 7 mà không chào các
bạn nhé
khi sex